[موسيقى]
تخيلوا لو في وقت بطلتوا تعملوا حاجه انتم
ناجحين فيها
[تصفيق]
انا نور بدات العب كاراتيه من وانا عندي
ست سنين الاول انا طالبه في كليه طب اسنان
دلوقتي بدات العب كاراتيه من ست سنين من
عندي ست سنين ما كنتش عارفه ايه الهدف من
لعب الكاراتيه لان طفله صغيره اهلي ودوني
رياضه افرغ فيها طاقتي واستفاد بوقتي كل
المدربين كانوا شايفين ان انا شخص متميز
وموهوب جدا فبداوا يركزوا معايا اكتر بدات
ادخل بطولات تنشيطيه تبع النادي وكلها كنت
بجيب فيها مراكز اولى كبرت شويه ومن حظي
ان انا اتمرنت مع ابطال عالم في الوقت ده
هم كمان كانوا شايفين ان انا مشروع بطله
كبيره ومن هنا حطيت لنفسي هدف ان انا
عايزه ابقى زيهم انا عايزه اجيب بطوله
عالم الموضوع ما كانش سهل تماما
كنت بجيب دايما اول قاهره اول جمهوريه
واجي عند تصفيات المنتخب بخسر فضلت اخسر
خمس سنين وكل ما كنت بقع كنت بكرر اقوم
اقوى من الاول انا عايزه اجيب بطوله
العالم وسنه 2019 دي اعز واعظم سنه عدت
علي في حياتي السنه دي جبت اول تصفيات
منتخب وسافرت التمن بلاد بره كلنا بتقول
كنت برجع منها كنت بنزل المطار بميداليه
ما فيش بطوله نزلت المطار غير بميداليه
واغلىهم هم كانوا كانوا مركز اول كل ده
انا برضو ما وصلتيش لحلمي انا عايزه اجيب
بطوله العالم والحمد لله بفضل ربنا كسبت
تصفيات المنتخب اللي تاهلني لبطوله العالم
سافرت بطوله العالم وقدرت اكتب اسمي في
تاريخ الكراتين المصري ببرونزيه بطوله
العالم
الموضوع يبان ان هو سهل وبسيط الا ان حلمي
وهدفي ده بغض النظر عن خمس سنين اللي فضلت
اعافر فيهم سنه 2019 خدتني عن اهلي
واصحابي بطريقه مش طبيعيه سنه بحالها مش
في البيت دايما معسكرات دايما مسافره
لدرجه ان انا اخويا كان بيخطب السنه دي
وانا ما اعرفش عنه حاجه لاني في معسكر ومش
معايا موبايلي ومعرفش اي حاجه كانت حياتي
من صاله التمرين والاوضه وصلت التمرين
والاوضه الا ان بعد ما نزلت من المطار
مدربي قال لي نور انت بداتي طريق العالميه
الكاراتيه ما كانش بالنسبه لي لعبه او هدف
عايزه اوصل له او حلم لا انا اتربيت في
قناتي عشت تقريبا 13 سنه في الكاراتيه
الكاراتيه كان بالنسبه لي بيتي التاني كان
مايكونفرد زون زعلانه بروح التمرين فرحانه
بروح التمرين مخنوقه بروح التمرين حتى لو
مخنوقه من التمرين برده بروح التمرين ده
المكان اللي كنت بحس بيه بنفسي بحس اني
متالقه بحس اني متميزه كنت دايما بحس
بالفخر
وبعد كده
رغم كل اللي حصل معايا السنه دي من حاجات
كتير صعبه تعرضت لها الا اني قررت لما
انزل من العطار اجدد هدفي في اللعبه ومش
عايزه بس اكون جبت بطوله عالم للشباب لا
انا عايزه ابقى اصغر لاعبه تجيب بطوله
عالم كبار والحقيقي كل المدربين كانوا
شايفين اني اقدر على حاجه زي دي وانا كمان
كنت شايفه كده
وطبعا جت كورونا في الوقت ده سنه تقريبا
وصلت لنا مصر احنا 2020
في الوقت ده احنا تقريبا كل الرياضيات
يعني اتقصروا في ردات وقفت تماما وفي
لعيبه ما عرفتش تتمرن بس احنا كلعيبه
كاراتيه كنا قادرين نمنتج ده وكنا بنتمرن
من البيت عادي كانوا دائما بيقولوا لنا
خليكوا جاهزين لاي حاجه الا ان ما كانش في
معالم لاي حاجه واضحه في الوقت ده اغلبنا
ان ما كانش كلنا راجع قراراته اولوياته في
حياته همم حسيت في الوقت ده ان انا اه انا
فرحانه ومبسوطه بالهدف والحلم اللي وصلت
له
الا انا حسيت ان النجاح بتاعي كان شخصي
شويه حسيت ان انا عايزه اعمل حاجه يكون
لها اثر ما توقفش مهما الدنيا وقفت الحاجه
بتاعتي تفضل مستمره والنجاح بتاعي يفضل
مستمر ما يوقفش ابدا يمكن مش ده السبب
الوحيد اللي كان فيه اسباب تانيه كتيره
طبعا
في الوقت ده
قررت اعتزل
طبعا قرار اعتزالي كان صدمه بالنسبه لي
قبل ما يكون صدمه لاي حد حرفيا قرار
اعتزالي كان قنبله الموسم ازاي تعتزلي
وانت جايبه بطوله عالم انا كنت لسه راجعه
بطوله العالم وروحي متشوقه ومتحمسه
الانجازات اكتر لان انا كنت واثقه اني
اقدر اعمل اكتر من كده
حقيقي قلت لنفسي في الوقت ده خلاص هنقول
انت شخصيه ناجحه هتعرفي تنجحي في اي حاجه
ثانيه
بس قابلتني مفاجاه ما كنتش متوقعاها هي ان
انا ما اعرفش اصلا مين نور انا اعرف نور
امكانياتها جوه ملعب الكاراتيه بره ملعب
الكاراتيه ما اعرفش مين نور مش عارفه حاجه
عن نفسي طبعا بسبب ان كورونا كانت قافله
كل حاجه فكان شبيه بدايل كثيره ان انا
اطلع طاقتي ثاني فيها
ودخلت في اكتئاب حاد اكتئاب حاد يعني
وصلني للانتحار لكذا مره اتحولت من شخص
برودكتيف وعنده اهداف وعارف امكانياته
قادر يحققها لشخص مش عارف امكانياته ما
عندوش اهداف مش عارف يعمل اي حاجه في
حياته
في الوقت ده حسيت ان انا مش بس بواجه قرار
اعتزالي وحبي للعبه الا اني في دوامه انا
انا انا تايهه انا مش عارفه نفسي انا مش
عارفه اعمل ايه قلت لنفسي يا نور حاولي في
اي حاجه حواليكي برده ما كانش في بدايل
كثيره بس قلت هحاول في اي حاجه انا برضو
شخصيا ناجحه وتاني صدمه تحصلني وهي اني
اترفض في الحاجه اللي اقدم فيها ازاي ازاي
انا نور بطله العالم اللي عليها الدوق
سوبر ستار اللي دايما بتحقق اهدافها وتوصل
لكل حاجه هي عايزاها تترفض قرار الرفض ده
دخلني في اكتئاب يعني انا كنت في اكتئاب
زاد اكتئاب اكتر نفسيتي بقت تحت الصفر ما
بقاش عندي ثقه في نفسي وما كانش عندي اي
حاجه اعملها
اتحولت من شخص كان ليه صحاب ودايما بيخرج
ويضحك واللي يعرف نور يعرف ان هي قد ايه
شخص ضحوك الناس بتحب تقرب منها وتضحك
معاها الشخص دايما قاعد في البيت مش عايز
يقوم من على السرير مش عايز يصحى اصلا رحت
لدكتوره وطبعا كتبت لي على انت دبرنس عشان
اقدر اعدي يومي واقوم اصلا من السرير وفي
الوقت ده
قالت لي انت عامله زي ما تكوني ملفوف
حواليكي سلاسل حديد وانت بتحاولي تفكيها
باقوى ما عندك وحقيقي ده كان ادق وصف
للاحساس اللي انا فيه
في الوقت ده قلت لنفسي يكون الداعم الاول
والاخير لنفسك يا نور يا تكوني عدويه نفسك
الاول والاخير انت مريتي بحاجات كثير قوي
عشان توصلي لحلمك بطوله العالم وما كانش
الموضوع سهل فهتعرفي تطلعي من ده
ولان دايما الايه بتاعه وان ليس الانسان
الا ما سعى وان سعيه سوف يرى ثم يجزاها
كانت دايما محفوره في دماغي من اول ما انا
كنت بسعى لحلمي كانت برضو محفوره ان انا
هطلع من اللي انا فيه ده وهرجع انجح من
ثاني
وفعلا خرجت من الاكتئاب
والنهارده يبقى بقى لي اربع شهور بطلت اخد
انتي دي بريسين دراجز
الرحله دي كانت صعبه عليا جدا ومؤلمه
وعمري ما اتمنى ان حد يمر بيها الا اني ما
كنتش اعرف اعديها من غير اهلي وبالاخص امي
واصحابي الا ان كان في شخصيه مؤثره جدا في
حياتي كانت دايما جنبي وكان الشخص ده
ساعدني اني اوصل لحلمي في الاول وكان اكتر
واحد داعم ليا في قراري اعتزالي وكان واقف
جنبي لحد ما عرفت الاقي نفسي تاني واحقق
اهداف جديده فالفضل يرجع له بعد ربنا
اللي عايزه اقوله
ان مهما الدنيا صعبت علينا حاجه هنوصل
ربنا مش هيحطنا في حاجه غير وهو عارف ان
احنا قادرين عليها
ولو سالتوني لو رجع بيا الزمن هكرر نفس
القرار ده تاني
لان لولا القرار ده انا ما كنتش هعرف مين
نور ما كنتش اعرف قدراتي ما كنتش اعرف اني
قويه قوي كده اوقات كتير بنخاف ناخد خطوات
وقرارات في حياتنا لان احنا خايفين احنا
احنا مش عارفين قدراتنا حطينا فيها بنكتشف
ان احنا اقوى بكثير مما كنا نتصور وان انا
ابطل حاجه كنت بعملها وناجحه فيها مش
معناها ان انا هفشل في حاجه تانيه خالص لا
انا دلوقتي حطيت لنفسي اهداف جديده وبدات
اخد اتجاهها خطوات يمكن تبان صغيره لاني
واثقه ان اي نجاح كبير بيبدا بخطوات صغيره
وده الميكانيو اللي في حياه كل واحد فينا
والنهارده انا بشارككم انجاز جديد السنه
دي انا كنت عايزه اكسر حاجز الخوف من نقف
واتكلم قصادكم ودلوقتي انا معاكم بشارككم
جزء من قصتي بس اتمنى المره دي اكون سبت
اثر طيب
[تصفيق]